okay
good evening and welcome to this
overview and scrutiny committee meeting
on Tuesday the 28th of March
my name is councilor Paula spencerley
and I'm the vice chair of this committee
sitting as the chair tonight
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded during
each item please put your hands up to
indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can I ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished
please reference the page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
and we move to apologies for absence may
I have the apologies for absence please
Sean
uh Brian Beale Bell
heard Helm and Hugo thank you chair
thank you
um so we moved to the minutes it's
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 24th of January 2023
found on pages five to eight are
approved as a true and accurate record I
so move do I have a seconder for that
motion please that's councilman thank
you so we agreed by a cent thank you
right so now we move to um disclosure of
Interest so this is to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other pecuniary
interests or non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph six to
eight inclusive of the code of conduct
for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
so we moved to public participation I
can advise that we have not received any
submissions from members of the public
tonight
so now we're
well fast okay so we move on to agenda
item six found on pages nine to 14 which
is the annual report of the overview and
scrutiny committee and for that I'm
going to turn to Mr Jennings and ask him
to please present the report
thank you madam chairman
um this is an annual task of the
committee
um part of its terms of reference is to
report to council annually on its work
over the past year
and that represents a degree of
accountability to council
um
the covering report
merely sets the scene all of the
um
the information which is entirely
factual
um I believe is is contained in the
appendix
and
um
it covers all of the items referred to
the committee and accepted for
consideration whether added to the the
scrutiny work plan or not without comes
and the two uh little pieces of of
highlighting are merely a reminder to me
and others to update that report as a
result of this meeting
and that report will then lend its way
to Council in May
okay thank you Mr Jennings
um so we've got a recommendation on page
nine which is actually the
recommendation to the council so I don't
think that would be our recommendation
if I could ask you Mr Jennings it really
the recommendation will be that the
annual report of the overview and
scrutiny committee for 2022 to 2023 be
accepted
um so before we move to any debate on
that do I have a second uh thank you
councilor Mays
um so do any of the members wish to make
any contribution on that before we take
the vote
thank you councilor Mays
uh yeah thank you um Madam chairman
there's just a couple of um queries I've
got
um for example on um notice of motion
relating to successful planning appeal
which is the uh what third one down yeah
third one or third item I mean there are
recommendations on there about reviewing
and protocols and stuff like that and it
was accepted at Council
um will this come back at some point to
see how things are progressing and if uh
recommendations were taken on board and
it has actually moved forward because
there's no point in making such
recommendations if we don't take them on
and we just ignore them thank you very
much Council amazing it's actually in
our next item
so we're going to be moving to look at
that and I'm hoping from that well you
wouldn't know that because when I first
looked at the report for the next item I
couldn't quite work that out and had to
ask Mr Jennings so I think we will come
to that in a moment so so um following
on from that can I agree that by a sense
is that fine
thank you thank you so that's agreed
so now we're moving on to
um agenda item seven to be found on page
15 which is the scrutiny work plan item
for planning decision making
um again I'm going to ask Stuart
Jennings
um to present and provide a brief
explanation of how we might resolve to
take this matter forward thank you
Stuart
yes the very point and question as
raised by councilor Mays
um
this committee
made recommendations on certain elements
of the entirety of the piece of work
headed up planning decision making and
at the February Council
those the recommendations on those three
items were agreed what council didn't do
and perhaps it needed to be pointed in
the right directions but never mind
um was to decide
Beyond supporting them where they would
go for Action so the purpose of this
item really is to pick up
those items again to make sure that they
are not forgotten and are sent in the
direction
it's felt they should go with now the
council support
so that's the that's the first task for
this committee to perhaps endorse that
they go in those three items go in the
direction as suggested for
implementation
okay so thank you very much for that
Stuart so I'm going to take it back to
the floor I have actually prepared some
possible motions myself but first I'd
like to hear some thoughts anybody has
any further thoughts on that councilor
Mays oh yeah thank you madam chairman uh
can I ask who's going to be leading on
this please
in terms of when we take it back to
somebody else when we
suggested courses of action yes I'll
turn to Mr Jennings
as long as this the generality of this
item which
um still exists remains in the ownership
of this committee then obviously I and
colleagues
um supporting this committee will will
um stay with it
um but of course once it
um is referred to another committee then
if it requires input and support from
other specialist officers then then they
will join in that process
so so the way that I've I've
can't motion here which
which Mr Jennings please give us some
some help on this if it's not quite what
it needs to be that the committee
endorses the individual matters now
accepted by the council and makes a
suggested references for these actions
so to take that forward part two that
the committee brings forward at a future
date the other remaining conclusions
arising from the scrutiny undertaken so
that we need to perhaps debate a bit
more in a moment
and part three that the committee
retains planning decision making as a
scrutiny work plan item going forward so
that further work can be carried out to
add to that already completed and to
facilitate bringing forward further
recommendations to council at a future
date
does that sound are you okay with those
three I'd second that motion all three
parts of that okay does everybody agree
with that by a cent to take that foot
because stop Mr councilman Morgan I was
just I mean the timing of this is can
you perhaps be a bit more clearer as to
how where you see the chronology
particularly in view of the forthcoming
elections in verse Olympics
I can ask for you another chairman
Council Morgan are you asking in
relation to the items to be referred on
or the remaining items to be picked up
well all of them frankly it's okay well
the three items here will will go
directly as as identified there
clearly if there if there are
um if there's a working group to be held
then that will be picked picked up
immediately if there's not another
meeting of the performance governance
and audit committee be before
um the elections and obviously the
review and refresh of the planning
appeals protocol will require some
Preparatory work to be done in order to
present it for review and refresh so I
suspect that time is largely against us
to do a great deal of work but the
important thing for the committee
perhaps here now is to
signpost and direct it to to make sure
that momentum isn't lost and it can be
picked up immediately after the
elections
yeah thanks
um
there was something I wanted to pick up
on some of the earlier part as well that
was regarding the The Five-Year housing
land Supply working group and exactly
can you explain exactly what
responsibility this committee now has in
respect for that working group going
forward
it's not a working group of this
committee so although the committee was
created from emotion from this working
group
believe that's correct that I it doesn't
actually it's not owned it's not owned
by this committee so we no longer have
any oversights at all that thanks
Council uh yeah on from uh councilor
Morgan
um I am assuming that we could ask for
that to come back to this community for
scrutiny in the next session
The Five-Year land Supply yes yes sorry
yes it's a private land Supply yes
this is one thing that's sort of
burdening my inbox quite considerably at
the moment yeah I think indeed something
about you and me both I suspect so it
would be very helpful if we actually
brought that back in and the five-year
The Five-Year Line supply as a scrutiny
item
I would second that
um proposal I think that's going to be
separate from what we're proposing here
do you think what would you think Mr
Jennings
can we add it to the motion here is that
appropriate
yes I think I think it does because this
is not a it was almost a matter that was
perhaps um perhaps to be picked up and
followed up from from the annual report
because it was dealt with there but it's
it's not a matter which is under the
planning decision-making subject per se
well it's linked well yes
surely it's key to the planning decision
yeah yeah okay it's it's linked but it
it's not part of the the issues being
reported on here and now but the
committee
um if if all the committee is doing is
flagging up a wish to bring back that on
the scrutiny work plan at one at one
time that's purely procedural yes
add something to
do we move forward with this with the
fourth part of this motion which is now
a fourth part
um yeah thank you madam chairman um I
think I will uh liaise with my
colleagues and we will ask for it to go
onto the work plan through the
um the normal scrutiny requests the
scrutiny requests thank you that's a
good that's a good that's a good plan
absolutely I I will liaise with both of
you on on that particular and myself oh
of course yes of course
no please don't I should feel yes we do
that on Thursday during the break no
thank you that seriously we must end up
there so do I have it so I do I have a
second year for the for the three-part
motion okay I'll take counselor Morley
this time just to make sure he's not
left out okay and can we agree that with
a fire scent
great thank you
I knew this would be fun tonight okay so
we're going to move on to a Tim it's his
sorry I'd say that again yes a gender
item eight I thought I've got my numbers
wrong on pages 17 to 19 and it's the
report
um potential scrutiny work plan item
planning enforcement and I have this
here as a member of the working group
um to present to you so I hope that you
know I'm not going to read through the
whole theme because I'm hoping that
members have have read this but I would
draw your attention particularly
to paragraphs 3.5 and 3.6 on page 18.
um
and we have here and I will just read a
cut these out process mapping for the
life of cases would be developed however
this was likely to be rather Ideal World
and therefore represent an aspiration in
the present circumstances link to this
would be a further review of the
enforcement policy which would need to
align with the process map and better
reflect degrees of any prioritization a
more accurate assessment and a
recommendation as to resources should
ideally await completion of the master
spreadsheet since this would give a
truer picture of the overall workload
and I think this was one of the reasons
why the recommendation talks about
making carrying this forward
as a watching brief but I also have some
concerns that we need to have maybe add
more to the idea of the watching brief
in the motion I I shall I shall cut
certainly come to come to you in a
moment councilor Mays the second point
that I wanted to point out at 3.6 was
the office was the well the concept of a
compliance officer would be an ideal
component of any enforcement team to
have a conditions monitoring officer to
dovetail in with the work of development
management might be a better solution a
critical look at the extent and
enforceability of planning conditions
imposed generally would be a useful
exercise changes to the mppf were likely
to provide greater clarification in this
respect planning committee members had a
role to play here looking critically at
officer reports and recommendations as
to conditions but the point that that
comes out there is again around Staffing
and resourcing
and I just think that you know we I I'll
read out I'll read out to you and then
I'll I'll move to the debate the
recommendation and then we can take the
debate forward that the committee
receives this report on the issues and
concerns previously raised and accepts
the conclusion of the working group that
this item Remains the subject of a
watching brief for further review after
May but I'm going to open the debate up
now because I do know that some of my
colleagues here have things that they
would like to say so I'm and who would
like to speak on this
was that an indication as well from
okay
okay I'll start with start with you
councilor mace uh yes thank you madam
chairman I'm actually going to just
refer to the points that you uh
highlighted I agree
um process mapping my major concern is
basically nothing has happened as far as
I can work out for the last six months I
know that may seem very unfair but
certainly as a member I don't see that
anything has actually uh come to
fruition uh that was on 3.5 and 3.6
compliance officer
How likely is that to ever come to
fruition
um and
um also there there's the recommendation
for conditions and that sort of thing
now that that in and I it seems actually
perfect in an ideal world but how does
one do it as a member we have received
no training on how to actually put
forward any sort of condition what is
reasonable what's not reasonable
um in actually moving forward and I
think this is something that perhaps
should be flagged up and go to
um the training the member training work
working group I think yes I think that's
what I said on
um
because I I have no idea all I know is
that you know somebody wants a
particular uh condition and yet actually
at the end of the day we are Bamboozled
and overridden by planning officers who
obviously know a lot more than we do
but we stand no chance
but we do need to know how to do it we
need a process
to do it
because it's not happening well thank
you Council amazing I have just been
told whilst you've been speaking to me
we do have Anne here who can give us a
bit of an overview of changes so what I
might actually do rather than keep going
back and forth is if I can take comments
from the other members and then we might
come we go switch to our and then if
that's that's possible is that okay Anne
we're going to do it that way fantastic
okay so who else would like to speak
councilor Morley thank you chairman
um
last time we discussed it it was
compliance do you mean following up on
the conditions that they have been
complied with by the Builder I I do
remember them saying it's an absolute
Minefield trying to get around
all the plane that has been granted and
and firing up if they've done what the
conditions were yeah yeah how I just
wondered how things are panning out with
the council in gaining staff or or
following it up really that was all okay
thank you thank you councilor more Lisa
and councilor Morgan
uh yes secretary
um essentially from my point of view
there is a major training issue here uh
in respect of particularly members and I
think this is something that needs to be
looked at obviously when the new intake
comes in in May
um but there is a particular issue with
my award where there is no doubt that
the conditions that had been imposed of
the planning application were simply not
fit for purpose and I think that if the
members have been had a better informed
as to how those things could be worded
it would mean a lot better and I think
that this is a general lack of
um you know well essentially training
and competence that within within the
ability to scrutinize what the
conditions that officers are seeking to
impose or or indeed seek to impose their
own conditions that actually can tie
these things down a lot better so I
think there's a crucial crucial Gap
there that needs to be filled
thank you thank you councilor morning
that sounds very sensible
um anybody else want to speak at all
Council amazing
[Music]
because I have no idea
um it seems to be the lowest branch is
looked at and yeah that seems to be easy
to pursue
um one of the specific categories of
enforcement what are protocols out of
house investigations well how's that
going to work who's going to do it
um I don't know
um closing cases who's responsible for
closing cases how do how do we get them
off this list so we actually can see the
reality rather than the reality
um
the idea of a compliance officer uh if
it's something you want and other uh
authorities have gone
3.2 what is the current level and I
think we need to know what our current
level is not what it might be or what it
was three months ago but also what it
was like three years ago four years ago
is there any trend is it literally one
or two that come in not this 560 which
is clearly
specifically big
who is the lead specialist local plans
and implementation I understand from
from Mr Jennings that that is actually
um Mrs Shoreland
um for that but I'm not I'm not entirely
sure
self-help mapping app
is being looked at is there is there a
likelihood of this being
um
one of my biggest vampires though is 3.3
and has come up time and time of day and
that is a couple of paste function
please stop using it
the use of plain English
as a general member of the public will
be able to understand
and appalling
and I mean appalling grammar
that along with attendance by officers
some not all and not all at some times
so some of those officers don't always
do it you know they're appropriately
dressed there is a lack of
professionalism out on the street that's
the perception that I am being given
I don't know I haven't seen them in
action would be great to see them in
action
they're not showing ID cards there's
there's just I'm a planning officer I
can do what I like I have the the power
to do this that and the other
um and there's a whole lack of
actually we're dealing with human beings
here at the end of the day let's be kind
to one another please okay I'm going to
stop you there I'm going to stop you but
no that that's brilliant thank you very
very thank you very much Council amazing
I'm going to pass that now to Anne for
some response on there's lots there and
sorry for you but I thought rather than
go back and forth
excellent thank you very much
um we've had permission to employ an
additional officer
so we're writing the job description now
actually but we want to get that person
in post as soon as possible if we can
get an experienced officer we will try
our hardest to do that but I'm not
holding my breath we may have to have
somebody who's new at the job
we are going to try and design that job
so that it can look at compliance
of conditions but I think to start out
with is they're going to have to be a
general enforcement officer trying to
get the backlog of cases down we lose
our Contracting officer at the end of
the month so we'll be one down and there
will be one down who was a contractor
and then we'll have somebody imposed
full-time permanent so the team will
consist of
um one principle and three officers and
part-time admin member of staff
so that's quite good news really because
that's a that's a bolstery to the team
which it is it's a full-time permanent
member of staff
and in terms of I'll just go over the
number of cases we've got because I
think that was a an issue so at the
moment we've got 562
open cases
I've closed off
180 since the beginning of January since
January the 1st so we all we're all
getting through them
there's another 83 sat there to be
written up to be closed so once we get
those closed off there'll be about 479
cases
um live to be dealt with but out of
those 479 cases
for for 126 of those are from 2022
onwards and the rest are from our old
cases so we've still got that backlog
lurking round that we're trying to deal
with
we are getting there it is slow so the
master spreadsheets down there so
they're all on a master spreadsheet and
they're being managed to
registered effectively than than they
ever were before we've got 11 notices in
the pipeline to deserved we've served
two since January
um
so that's the prime name with regards to
training there is a session a mandatory
session for planning enforcement after
the May elections for all members
and we can put in additional training
sessions as the year goes through as I
just wish that I think that's quite a
good idea to include a session at some
point on some conditions and what they
are and what they look like and what
they should look like and I think that
would be a good a good session for
training
sorry continue and sorry sorry
I'm sorry I was gonna say in regards to
out of hours investigations the team
doesn't do out of various investigations
but what they do is they tend to if
they've got to go somewhere and they're
trying to for instance catch somebody
who they think's living there
same as a caravan site or something like
that they would go very very early in
the morning that's the best time to
catch people uh the catching it and
catch them you know of unaware
if they have got somebody who's working
after hours say after six o'clock they
might go half past six but they don't
they are not they're not um employed to
go out at 11 o'clock at night or
anything like that not at the moment
it is something that you know the
council wishes to discuss it can do
with regard to the self-help then we're
mapping that that is actually nearly
finished
so um we're going to roll that out onto
the elections probably at the training
session of members for enforcement we've
got to move a lot of the data to the new
place on the computer system of the
council but the mapping app itself is
actually unfinished and that will mean
that members will have access they'll
log into the Phoenix mapping system
they'll have their own login and you'll
be able to self-help with regard to what
how important the cases are going and
it'll be a weekly update instead of this
email with a log list it will be done in
parishes that she said it on the map and
you just click in and it'll come up and
it'll have an update which will be much
more effective than what it is
thank you
um I think that was all the questions
wasn't it the other one um I was just
the thing that I was Raising around
policy review and when that's happening
and obviously looking to which I I'm
probably going to add to our motion
looking at that as a focus as well from
overview and scrutiny being that we've
had the issues that we have and that we
have the report that we do before us
um do you know when that policy review
will happen because one of the things
that I I observed for example was that
um as you said
um from when you came and to speak to
the working group certain issues need to
be prioritized as in fact um councilor
Mays was also saying but within that
policy it doesn't really the time limit
that's given isn't very immediate for
those things which need high priority or
I couldn't see that it was and I just
wonder if
um when you do the review it would be
quite nice I think if we do keep and I'm
going to actually motion and we'll see
what members think in a moment rather
than keeping it as a watching brief but
to actually take it forward as a
scrutiny work plan item with a focus on
policy review resourcing and on and on
an ongoing review as well I'm thinking
of doing that because we want in a
supportive manner actually yeah and so
that we're there to to because then if
necessary from our findings we can then
um yes exactly we can understand and we
can also then make recommendations to
other committees so you know I think I
think it I think that that's probably
that we would be the right committee to
be carrying on with that and that's my
feelings on it and do you know when the
review might happen of the policy
no because
I presume
carry on you know I would want to do it
probably after the elections I think we
need to get our our officer in place yes
I think we need to get those numbers
down because
the problem is when you're doing that
work of the other work you're not doing
you're not doing enforcement no I
understand you know so I think maybe
after the elections it is the right time
to do it and I yes I I do agree I think
members
oh I think members should be involved in
that and help us to set the priorities
and to look at the processes yes and be
happy to be happy with it I mean in
reality a list of building or a tree
case you should be going out either the
day yes the next day but they are the
top priorities because they are an
offense yes and then you need to kind of
work a gradient down from that on how
quickly you're going to see things and
we don't particularly have that I don't
think it's clear and I think reading the
room here tonight and also thinking um
forward because obviously there will be
a change of administration after May
um I have a feeling that with things as
they are because we're not at that place
yet this will only end up coming back
otherwise there's another scrutiny
request and then we could go back to
square one so I'm thinking actually that
we should um amend the motion that we
the recommendation that we had before us
tomorrow or less what I was saying
saying there okay so let's let's see if
we can work on that motion so it was
um that the committee receives this
report on the issues and concerns
previously raised and and accepts a
conclusion of the right I think so we
need to change that raised and
um
keeps this item
would that be right
um as the subject of a what keeps this
item as a scrutiny work plan item
what do you think of the wording there
just do it just on that point Madam
chairman it's been described as a
potential scrutiny item because it's
it's been going back and forth between
the the committee and the working group
to establish more information and
understanding I think if you're wishing
to make it a scrutiny work plan item as
of now to give direction going forward
then actually say so okay so take that
operative decision brilliant that this
committee receives this report on the
issues and concerns previously raised
and adoptsis are adopts this item as a
scrutiny work plan item
I think we'll go forward with that I'd
also like to add a line map do we need
to add a line with a focus on policy
review I think res Staffing resource and
ongoing review as well in terms of the
performance the ongoing performance
review so that would be fantastic and
then because we don't know after the
election whether what the setup will be
whether it will be a working group
whether it be the whole committee so I
think that that makes sense to take it
forward and not lose the work that we've
already already completed okay thanks
ever so much for that and it's really
appreciated
thank you members so we're going to move
on now
to vote Madam chairman
I'm excited and we've got we've got
Council a bill
[Laughter]
okay right basically uh there was some
good news and bad news here I mean
Anne's turned around and told us that
she's got rid of 180 enforcements was
that because
they were resolved
because they lost the will to live or
the lack of staff to actually close them
off
um and on a positive note I'm so glad
that we are going to
break it down into parishes
because I mean I think the last time I
looked it was 318 pages and I lost the
will to live after 158 I think it was
it was just ridiculous but at least if
we can condense it into specific areas
you haven't got to go through the whole
lot
I think Council Bill rather than get and
back again I think we conclude from the
first thing that you said that probably
cases that have gone were a mixture of
all of those things as well as some that
have been resolved and unfortunately
that's what we've I think we've you know
this committee's got to try to help and
support the officers to resolve going
forward is my my view of it I don't know
if everybody agrees with that but can I
have a secondary to the motion because I
nearly went without voting yeah so it's
been historical
ever since I've been on the council it's
normally been lack of staff and I think
we've had like 1.25 members of Staff but
Anne's now saying there's like three or
four of them so I think that's all the
more reason why it's time to take this
forward as an item for after May
so um
so I have it seconded there by councilor
Mays can I agree by Ascent or does
anybody else all agree by a cent good
fantastic it's been done properly
wonderful okay so moving on to
um a gender item nine which is to be
found on page 21. and it's a potential
scrutiny item referred from performance
governance and audit committee otherwise
known as PGA
um and I I have here
um Stuart's going to go through the
report that we have here it's just a
single page report
um and then I think we'll we'll go
through discussing it further after that
thank you Stuart
yes Madam chairman at this point
um or this stage
um it is for the committee to actually
formally accept the reference from PGA
and decide how to deal with it either to
add it to its scrutiny work plan or or
whatever so
um the purpose of the note is little
more than to set the scene for
um the position as reported
to PGA PG a committee at the time this
matter was referred nothing more than
that but of course I do understand that
members do have some issues and there
has been a further audit report reported
and considered
um by the PGA committee which may result
in issues that members now wish to pick
up but as I say it's it's a question
first of all to actually accept
the reference from PGA of this item and
decide what to do with it thank you very
much for that Stuart okay so I am going
to move to the debate but before I do I
would like to highlight the link that's
in the report because to me that was
very important because you get a lot
more detail from reading the audit
report itself that we had the link to
and I can see that we've got Mr Geller
with us here
um who hopefully I'm going to go through
the same thing
um Daniel and I'm going to ask members
to speak to this and then if you could
note some of those questions rather than
going back and forth I think that could
be a more useful way of proceeding do we
have
um anybody who'd like to comment on this
particularly I do but I'm going to wait
till everybody else has
councilor Morgan uh yeah because
I just really a question is there a
particular problem that has emerged that
this is needed to address or is it is it
just a people being sort of prudent and
cautious
my own questions but we'll take that
question thank you councilor Morgan
anybody else wish to speak
Council amaze
I've actually had good a good experience
thank you well Mr Geller
um of using the system although actually
finding the document that I needed to
fill in
um was not quite as easy to find
um I would like to see this on the work
plan and uh I will listen to the rest of
the debate and what you have to say
anybody else
okay so my my questions really and
concerns
um so to give a bit of context you know
I have been trained at with ofsted so
and I was in education for a long time
so I think we've all read the news
recently about the very tragic events
related to that safeguarding is a huge
issue it's not something which you can
just dismiss as one of those things I'm
not suggesting that anybody's done that
but I have to say that when I read the
audit report I had to you know almost
stick my hair back on because to me it
is quite and I think Mr Gellar you'd
agree with me there it's quite
concerning because it looks to me as
though we've had issues with ensuring
that contractors and volunteers are
properly DBS checked
it looks as though we've had issues with
the people named a safeguarding officers
still being the correct people that
unfortunately due to the pressure that I
know you really are all under that we've
had officers not able to attend the
meetings and forums in the way that we
would hope that they did and I can see
that all the recommendations for actions
there which are quite straight thought
forward but one of the things that I do
want to make clear straight away this is
not in any way of criticism this is my
hope that as a as a committee I would
like us to take this on as a scrutiny
work plan item because I think it's so
important and because I would like us
again to be supportive to officers to be
able to get this completely where it
needs to be
um and it it it's I don't necessarily
think it's that that far a reach I'm
sure that as Council amazes already
pointed out there is a lot of good
experience from members and other people
in in terms of the safeguarding practice
is here at Northern District Council but
nevertheless these weaknesses have been
identified in audit and it is something
that does seem to have gone on to some
extent since 2020 and I think that we
really do need rather than just to be
assured we need to actually have sight
of those processes and how they're being
implemented going forward so I would
recommend and I shall come to that after
you've answered the questions Mr Geller
that we take this forward as a scrutiny
item thank you
[Music]
is there a particular problem so in
terms of the safeguarding referral
process
um no I don't believe there's a
particular problem
um what basically caused um the risk
waiting to to increase if you like well
it was a preemptive measure so I could
see quite early on throughout our yearly
cycle of meetings uh that there was some
lack of attendance by debt that some of
the designated safeguarding officers
um and so we decided that we were going
to review that list if there's a data
set going offices now the very fact of
carrying out that review and the fact
that there were some officers that
couldn't attend some of those meetings
uh meant that I felt because we're just
waiting the wrist slightly to say look
we're going to do this review there are
some officers that are struggling with
attendance
um this won't impact me it has been put
into my um reports back this won't
impact our response to safeguarding it's
just a flank there's a risk in terms of
that meeting and some officers attending
what I would give reassurance to is
every case that's referred in
is reviewed by officers it's reviewed by
the site got fleets the safeguarding
meeting if officers aren't in attendance
of that we will automatically have
catch-ups in general and I are linking
with all the the designated safeguarding
losses at different points so hopefully
that gives reassurance that the cases
are being dealt with correctly it's
literally just a minor issue as far as
likings in terms of the attendance at
the safeguarding meeting
separately in relation to the audit
conditions cancer species that you
mentioned
um
there you are correct when the original
order to save Garden there were issues
flagged in relation to contractors and
volunteers now one of the reasons why
that was flagged up is because there
wasn't an overall list of contracts and
volunteers it was held on an ad hoc
basis now work has been ongoing and is
actually near completion in terms of
that contractors list of the volunteers
list in fact it's already been
pre-populated and the next stage is for
me to do a verification exercise then
there's the further process to that is
to contact the various contractors and
volunteers check what this they've got
in processes live they've got their own
one great because they should be
following that
if they haven't then they need to
adopters and
now we have that process so hopefully
that gives you some reassurance that
these issues are already being picked up
I think
is you know a very important subject the
fact that the risk rating was raised
um to the next level caused the concern
and they wanted the the whole process
reviewed and I'm happy to support
members in that so as my work continues
I'm happy to bring that back to our NSE
members of issue
thank you very much Mr Geller I I think
you know I'm really reassured by
everything that you're saying
um but I've still got this paragraph As
you say in this report that I have in
front of me you know the council also
uses other volunteer organizations
outside of events for example to support
the covid pandemic our discussions with
the director of world and a district CVS
a key volunteer Organization for the
council that the council worked closely
with confirmed that safeguarding issues
are being considered by the volunteer
organization however the council do not
currently request evidence that the
volunteer organizations are fulfilling
their safeguarding obligations and I'm
sure that you were as alarmed by that as
I was so I really do take all your
reassurance on board and I think it's
fantastic but I think rather than just
reassurance I would like to see once
you've gone through your process and
verified what you need to I'd like this
committee to have the chance to have
oversight of that
um can I can I can I speak sorry
councilor Morgan sorry
yeah it's just a quick question this is
a misprint
that says the council's safeguarding
policy was last updated in November
2000.
like is that is that is that the actual
date it was last updated it's a good
spot councilor Morgan can you answer
that sorry Mr Geller okay please repeat
the question please yeah sorry the in
the um the body in the paragraph areas
of concern the very last point it says
the council safeguarding policy was last
updated in November 2000.
um
[Music]
it's a good spot
it's a very good spot Council 2020
that's still that's still something
um I mean the other point is is I mean
I'm just wondering I was okay it's a
quick question
is this particular OAS the best
committee to do this particular
oversight in this particular area but I
just wonder what reviews there might be
all that
um I I will I will defer to Mr Jennings
on this but my my view would be that
without our principal thing is scrutiny
and this is something that in my opinion
would would require scrutiny to make
sure that the processes are as they are
because that's our duty to do that that
I will I will defer to Mr Jennings here
well given the um concerns that have
been uh identified and the reference
from the the committee Then There Are
Good Grounds for the committee to at
least take a a look at this obviously
um things like review of the policy and
the continued risk
um reporting through the quarterly
reports we'll go to the the other
committees as uh as existing but um yes
I agree
um anybody else wish to
thank you madam chairman
um well one's just been asked and
answered so
um was there a reason why there was a
lack of attendance in the
uh meetings at all or
thank you
unfortunately it's literally capacity
there were a small number of instances
where officers have moved posts and so
that was probably not
um appropriate to the current role
um that they that they sort of
safeguarding officer role but
predominantly it was it was capacity
thank you any other counselor maze just
one more from Council yes thank you
madam chairman um
how long should we be
um
deeming it
sufficient to actually
um ask for a conclusive report to come
back to this committee
are we are we looking at three months
are we looking at six months
um there is
a pot of work to do
and and we need to be mindful that
alongside this pot of work is other work
you know other other ongoing work of the
council and we should not be
unreasonable in the length of time that
we expect
um officers to come back to this
um I don't want it to keep coming back
and we are sending it away
um which I feel has happened with other
uh items of scrutiny that you know we
send it away it comes back and it's well
we're not really quite ready well okay
don't come back here if you're not ready
I as long as that's reasonable thank you
Council Amaze I will certainly um refer
to Mr Geller for that I mean my own view
is that it looks from this and from what
count from what Mr together has told us
that that probably this is something
which is going to be ready for us to
look at relatively relatively soon after
the or whoever's here relatively soon
after May
um would that be would that be right
Miss together
can I break it down into a couple of
areas hopefully the members benefit yes
um you've probably waste a concern about
the um uh contractor and volunteer uh
conditions requirements I'm hoping to
reach a conclusion to that hopefully by
um I would say May at the latest
um in terms of the designated
safeguarding offices I'm due to set the
uh the next em cycle of safeguarding
meetings
um at that first meeting we'll discuss
the new safeguarding officers
and then we'll monitor
um over the next couple of meetings how
they bids so
just the attendance at the Forum perhaps
he's brought back the member
consideration
um I would say after six months and in
terms of the the actual safeguarding um
strategy that you know it depends all we
do I'm looking to try and start work on
that towards the the third record the
later part of the year
um so any dates following that so
there's three elements to it in terms of
how I'm approaching the subject
it's not one that I want to leave for
too long because it's safeguarding so so
my my thoughts are that we should look
at six months and then any further work
that needs to be deferred that's of a
diff you know not of such an urgent
nature perhaps after that then we can
look at that uh Mr Geller and and then
decide because once it comes back as a
scrutiny work plan item of course it can
be carried on as a watching brief and
then have updates or we can do it as a
get get that report back
um but I'm quite anxious that we do have
something coming back to committee
certainly within six months I don't know
if anybody else feels that
that's right sorry um councilor Morgan
uh yeah it's just um I sort of thought
obviously
um social care is primarily a County
Council responsibility and I would be
interested to know uh from Mr Geller
which particular aspects of our own uh
activities given most concern in this
particular regard yes good question
so
as you mentioned you know it's a
district county split County have a
responsibility container that was adult
the children safeguarding elements of
safeguarding we are the referring
partner in if you ask me for the
robustness of as they've got a processes
in terms of our own internal discussions
referrals and actions I believe that
we're robust
but where we only where the process is
weak for more than if you like it and
this is a feature across all district
councils I've worked at it's the
interactions between ourselves and
County we we refer up to them very well
we don't always get the feedback cases
and that has been an ongoing concern
um like I said of course neighbors
Council I've been there it's something
we continue to work with there are
always channels in but it's it's a slow
process perhaps slower than I'd like so
hopefully that gives an understanding it
does thank you Damien
councilor Morley yeah just one it's
probably a bit simplistic
um are there challenges with
um volunteer vetting and things like
that are you able to get enough people
to
uh check do safety checks on the
volunteers and things like that and and
who who checks the people that check
them you know I I know you've got to
stop somewhere but be interesting to
know how it works really thank you
um I might need to get some kind of
points of clarification on that but what
I can tell you is that CVS are made
volunteer organization
um they engage in the Strategic theme
league for Community
um and discussions happen there about
what they want to do
um in terms of for example the DDS
checks and you know the volunteers being
brought in but my understanding is that
should be helped by the CBS and that is
definitely something that I need to
bottom out in terms of they're listed
down on the list of volunteers that will
refer to earlier on and I need to check
with them what they've got is it bigger
purpose
it isn't good for purpose they need to
sign up to ours and then I need to do a
discussion exercise with them so
you can see where the weaknesses and you
can see um hopefully the department
board
Council amazing then Council appeal
sorry cancel a bill first yes
thank you chairman
um I can confirm that CVS do help with
the DBS because I'm just going through
one at the minute
if you wanted something to deal with
children it's an enhanced so it's an
additional to
so it's not the same it's not a standard
DBS it's a lot more detailed
thank you councilor bill it's useful to
know councilor Mays uh yes oh thank you
um so we're looking at September October
um and I would respectfully ask that
this is actually programmed irrespective
of any single member here for September
or October 2023. uh that I think that
gives us uh the opportunity
um as well as officers to to think about
this whole this whole matter
um and obviously officers to to to do
the necessary work that needs to be done
and I know that is quite substantial
um but it is as you have quite rightly
said extremely important thank you thank
you very much councilor May so with that
in mind I'm actually going to put
forward a motion that the committee
adopts the council's safeguarding
um of children and vulnerable adults as
a scrutiny item and then it comes back
before the end of September 2023
okay so thank you thank you very much
and can I have the vote please Ascend
yes fantastic thank you thank you very
much Mr Gala thank you take care take
care thank you managed to take the vote
this time before saying thank you you're
moving on Okay so
we moved to
um any other items of business that um
that I've decided are Urgent and as far
as I can tell we have none
so moving on now to the exclusion of the
public and press
um the times that we was I'm sorry I
move the tons of section
1084 of the Local Government Act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following items of business on
the grounds that they involve the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph three of part one
of schedule 12a to the ACT and that this
satisfies the public interest test do I
have a second uh I take counselor Morgan
that's fine this time and we can agree
that by Ascent thank you chair I can't
actually see that
I'm in on the public one and when I've
tried to do it on the Internet it's not
letting me in
mind
so I'm sorry councilor Bill do you mean
you can't see the the next item I've
logged into it okay
okay well we'll move to that we'll move
to that because of the nature of the
matter after we've so we've got
agreement on the closure of the meeting
okay that's fantastic
but definitely do that thank you okay so
just I want to say thank you to
everybody who's been um watching us and
we will now then
um exclude the public and press and I'll
just wait to hear that the live stream
has gone off thank you very much